[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guests I'm
returning guest this week is the
headmistress of the Michaela school in
London
Katherine burbles sing welcome back to
trigonometry
thanks for coming on as I was just
saying to you before we started you're a
busy woman at the moment in demand you
were a news night last night you're
being interviewed and as you say you're
trying to set people straight about all
the nonsense that some people are
talking when it comes to education so
what is it the people are getting wrong
in view of the lockdown and what do
people misunderstand one of the things
that Frances and I really wanted to talk
to you about is this mythical idea that
somehow it's possible to have social
distancing in schools and anyone I think
who remembers being under the age of 18
realizes that it's just never going to
happen is that broadly of you yeah well
I mean that's that's what's strange it's
as if no one has ever been under the age
of 18 so they don't seem to remember um
social distancing and it's impossible as
as far as I can see now obviously if you
have 25 percent of the school there that
might be possible so when they talk
about a phased return let's say they
decide to just have the year Tenzin and
the year 12s because those are the new
groups that will be going through two
exams next year you could do it as I say
you could do it there will be difficulty
um for one you have to be taking the
entire timetable and people who don't
work in schools and this isn't anyone's
fault because they don't work in schools
um they don't know that a timetable
every year when the new timetable for
the next year is created it takes three
four five even six weeks for it to
appear and the timetable guy he's like
you know a slightly weird guy maybe a
bit of her new numbers and he goes away
into a room and locks himself away but
the days on end and then eventually
emerges with the time taken
that would be me if I was employed in a
school ID oh you just cut classes oh you
know you just throw in a bit of this
thrown a bit of that a little bit fine I
mean it's not so easy now I'm not saying
fun possible and okay let me see we're
all about being excellent so on so yeah
we'll do whatever whatever is required
but from a national point of view we
need to recognize that not all schools
will be in a position to be able to do
that and the so and then who are you
letting back in are you only letting
those children back in and everybody
else has to stay at home um or are you
letting everybody back in and if you're
letting everybody back in social
distancing is impossible I mean people
start posting things about you know
Chinese children wearing hats that are a
metre long to the schools in China have
you been to the schools in England
different places you know I'm saying
this as the headmistress of the
strictest pool in Britain you know but
we get over 600 visitors a year and
they're mainly teachers and they cannot
believe the order and the wonderful
behavior and saw I'm to a certain extent
if we had say 50% of kids 40% 30% we
would be able to do it but we have very
narrow corridors we're not the only
school in the country that has corridors
that are maybe just over a metre wide
the children are necessarily touching
each other when they pass but not only
that kids are kids they run up to each
other they hug each other they think
they do walk the other day and I'm gone
into one of them I did to a couple of
them actually separately and one of them
had these blue gloves on and she was so
excited to see me she came running up to
me would give me a big hug
so she was wearing the gloves was aware
of this idea of you know you need to you
need to protect yourself but then saw me
I wanted to give me a hug so because the
kids they don't kind of realise I'm
another boy we ran into he I dropped my
the cover of my um my water bottle he
immediately went and picks it up again
imagine eight hundred nine hundred
fifteen hundred children in a school
with narrow corridors in classrooms the
classrooms are only big enough to sit 30
kids right next to each other when they
come up out of their chairs to move out
of the classroom well they're
necessarily touching each other we're
handing out paper books pens all of the
time so I think sadly there are a lot of
people making pronouncements about what
is possible in school when they don't
actually work in schools so that's one
thing um but I do take the point so
people then think because I said social
distancing is impossible in schools
therefore I'm saying we shouldn't go
back to school I am NOT in the opinion
that we shouldn't go back to school for
some ten months that would be crazy
in fact I don't hold an opinion at all
about when we should go back and the
reason I don't hold that opinion is
because I feel I don't really know I'm
not a virologist I'm not an economist
I'm not an expert at these things so I'm
waiting for the experts to tell us when
they think is the right time for us to
go back and I will do as told
um and I know some people in the
education world very angry when they
hear that and they think no we should
all refuse to go back and I sort of
think what are we gonna refuse to go
back forever I mean I know at some point
we've got to go back and at some point
you need to try and make it work how
that happens I don't know and I'm not
saying what the right way is but I am
saying we need to trust the people who
are making these decisions and I think
that's the difficulty that sometimes
people have especially in education
because a lot of people in education are
left-leaning and the government of
course is right leaning so they feel
that they can't trust the government to
make the right decisions for them my
opinion on leadership is that you know
in my own school for instance I asked
the staff to trust me all the time with
decisions that I make it's the only way
anything works any organization only
works when you trust the leader and go
with the leader if we're all back
fighting and fighting all the time and
accusing the government of doing x y&z
then we're just gonna blow up I think um
so so yeah my position is social
distancing is
impossible but I do recognize that we
need to go back to school at some point
whenever that is you know I I genuinely
hope it's sooner rather than later I
miss the kids
I miss the stuff I miss the normal way
of doing things
you know I so obviously I would prefer
to go back but he said I want to put
people's lives in danger you know some
people as well have said the people who
are very antilock down you know they
come out with information saying well
it's it's there are studies that are
showing that children don't pass it on
as much I don't know how true that is
but certainly there are some people who
are saying that you know and the other
big action people who are wanting
schools to open up soon the big thing
that they don't take into account is
that they see children don't really pass
it on to each other so it's okay but
they're not giving any thought to the
teachers and I understand that the hurt
the teachers feel when they hear that
because they sort of think we'll sorry
do we not count do Our Lives not matter
and and there is I think a a tendency in
the country sadly this kind of teacher
bashing that I've seen which is not nice
where they there's no sense of
understanding that teachers are
currently working for instance or doing
what they can for the children in their
care and this sense that you teachers
get to work you're just a bunch of lazy
idiots um I I have a problem with that
and and of course there are lazy
teachers I mean you know I'd be the
first person to say that but there are
also some really hard-working teachers
out there who are giving their all at
the moment their whole Easter holiday
they'll have spent working for the kids
I know my own staff are a hundred
percent committed every child in our
school gets a phone call every week they
we're setting them video lessons we're
doing zoom lessons we're doing all sorts
of things for the kids
um so it's not really fair when people
then start accusing teachers of being
lazy when in fact you know some of them
are just genuinely concerned they're
saying wait a minute is my life going to
be in danger if I'm back in school and I
don't think
well there you go teachers lives matters
guys genuinely I'm I'm shocked by some
of the things that I hear people saying
about teachers now but there is some
truth in that you know I also hear on
Twitter this is when I say I hear I'm
taking my Twitter I hear some people
complaining and saying my child school
has gone dark we haven't heard anything
from them and actually parents listening
should should think to themselves this
is a good time to judge your school
actually have you been hearing much from
your school have you been getting lots
of work do you feel supported because if
you don't then actually perhaps it's not
a very good school you know and there
are good schools and there are bad
schools and that is something I know the
education system is not willing to
recognize they like to say that all
schools are brilliant and all teachers
are brilliant and of course as in any
profession there are you know there are
good lawyers and they're bad lawyers
there were good dentists and bad
dentists you know it's the same thing in
teaching and I think everyone would do
well to remember that both the
educationalists and the non education
list when making these judgments of
teachers because there are some who are
giving their all and there are others
doing anything so it's just a new and
Catherine one of the things that I
really want to discuss with you is what
effect is this having on the lowest the
children who come from the poorest
backgrounds the children who desperately
need that structure in school the kids
who school is really a safe haven for
them they must be really struggling with
this yeah yeah well no we need to
remember that schools are not closed
right they are open to vulnerable kids
who need that now so those children
ought to have some kind of check-in and
something that's happening on they're
either turning up school or or teachers
are involved in looking at in making
sure they are okay and there are
obviously a minority of children the
ones that we aren't talking about so
much are
are the ones who aren't doing any work
some of the listeners might think oh
that would have been me I wouldn't have
done anything and what we find at school
is that the children there are some
children who will do lots and lots of
working harder than ever before because
they've got families at home who are
very supportive and very keen on them
doing well and then there are others who
are not doing as much that's why we do
the phone call thing we do a phone call
with the child to try and keep them on
task and engaged in what's going on
sometimes families can't speak English
sometimes families have five or six
children there's no way that they're
going to be looking after their learning
other families don't engage in education
they don't believe in it they don't
think that it's gonna change their
child's life so they're not too bothered
oh who cares about your history who
cares about your science it doesn't
matter in fact that the house is so
chaotic that parent parent on on their
own with five children is thinking great
you've got a phone you can just sit
there on snapchat you can sit there on
Instagram and so on and that's a key
point again that people are
misunderstanding there is this whole
well this kind of made-up situation you
know I'd say made-up because I do feel
it's invented of all of the poor
children out there who cannot access
learning because all the learning is
happening online and if they don't have
a phone or a tablet then they're not
able to access it I think you'll find
that the vast majority of people do have
phones or tablet they have something to
be able to access and that in fact it's
the phone or the tablet that's
preventing them from working so on the
one hand we want them to have the tablet
to be able to get the video lesson or
the zoom lesson on the other hand that's
the thing that makes it so that they're
on snapchat and Instagram all the time
so that they're cutting out pictures of
themselves and putting them on a zoom
lesson so it makes it look like they're
there or they are sending emails in from
their parents email pretending that they
are the parent to say oh he's very ill
at the moment can't do it even imagine
all the tricks that they have you know
and um teachers have been thrown into
this situation you know they don't
necessarily
I mean imagine there's lots of teachers
who are over the age for my age and
older
they're not super experts at computers
and online learning and zooming and so
on so they have to learn all of that
really quickly and then they're having
to create Google classroom they've got
video lessons they've got all this stuff
they're trying to get their heads around
and their magic if they don't have a
parent at home I'm I'm who saying come
on now what's the work today what's been
said if that's not happening then with
it I'm so I do feel that there's this
kind of work signaling what's going on
you know we talk about virtue singling
well I think that there's a boxing link
that goes on so schools might you know
say I'm doing all these do lessons we're
doing this for doing that but how many
children are actually working that's
what every leader in education needs to
be asking themselves right now how many
children in your school are working so
we've got this whole spreadsheet which
teachers are filling out constantly
every week the width and the phone call
is checking online learning to see what
they've done and we're getting photos of
work that they've done and then on the
spreadsheet
I've got color codes and all sorts of
things so that so that the the e teacher
we call them rings is able to see in an
instant whether that child is doing what
we're asking them to do they're doing
half of what they're being asked or
whether they're doing nothing and then
that conversation can be had if on the
other hand you're just doing zoom
lessons and children are just you know
they're logging on or they're not
logging on and who knows and nobody's
tracking that then I think what's
happening is a lot of work signaling
going on but the work isn't actually
being done and I mean that's nobody's
fault I'm not blaming schools for that
this is all brand-new and it's very hard
and and over time michaela teachers you
know we've been learning we started
doing one thing then we did a bit
different you know and we have our zoom
meetings and we we figure out what's
best to get the most children working
most of the time you know but um but
this is hard and I think that we will
find at the end of this that that
I think schools will find that far fewer
children did the work than the perhaps
they thought they were they were doing
and that's where when we talk about
disadvantaged kids you know we're not
just talking about the ones with really
difficult parents who you know social
services need to be involved with which
is what you know we were talking about
earlier I'm just talking about kids
whose parents aren't really engaged in
education and whose parents aren't gonna
make them do the work and because
they're outside of school they're
outside of that environment where all
the children are working they're not as
committed as they would have been
otherwise and what it going to be what
are going to be do you think the
long-term implications of that that
we're going to have these kids a lot of
them from the very poorest sections of
society disenfranchised not connecting
not learning I mean it's gonna create a
massive gap between rich and poor isn't
it I mean I mean certainly on Newsnight
you know the various people they were
interviewing before we went on you know
live we're sort of saying this is the
end of the world oh my goodness this gap
that's gonna be created what are we ever
gonna do and look obviously I'm worried
about those kids and I we're doing
everything we can at a school to keep
those kids on task and we're already
thinking about well from September what
can we do to try and catch them up as
much as we can when we're thinking about
the Year tens or the year twelves well
the yuto's I'm not so worried about
actually they're on task
they're okay it's the Year tens I worry
more about there's more of them we're
slipping and um Emily then think okay
well we've got to the GCSE how can we
fix it so that they are prepared as well
as possible for that GCSE I mean so
these are issues um let me jump on that
do you think those exams that you're
talking about GCSEs a levels are they
actually gonna go ahead as normal do you
think I don't know I can't imagine that
they wouldn't they have they've already
had one year where the children haven't
had exams I mean I suspect the great
boundaries will drop massively but I
don't see any reason why they wouldn't
have
exams um hey you know I yeah the great
boundaries will drop and less will be
expected of the kids and that is
ultimately it I mean so when I do feel
people are catastrophizing a bit and
sort of saying oh my goodness what's
gonna happen these children and I mean
do these I mean remember I'm an
education but I also recognize that we
this is a pandemic you know this has
never happened before we want as many
people to live as possible that is more
important than whether or not they read
a Shakespeare play I mean look some
people might say oh my goodness people
seem saying it doesn't matter if they
haven't read a Shakespeare play I'm not
saying it doesn't matter but at the end
of the day we have to get through this
and so when we come out the other side
if we were to go back in the summer term
when I say summer term I mean after may
half term at some point before the
summer
I think things can be salvaged I don't
think it's the end of the world and I
think we'll be okay
hello and welcome to Palacio Orgazmo aka
my bedroom actually guys just a little
joke for you there I'm self isolating so
I am actually deeply alone however we've
got a brand new sponsor for this week
it's Harry's now if you don't know
Harry's they are eight shaving company
and they are absolutely brilliant in
fact I use Harry's on my face absolutely
so this is lovely
close shave that you see is a result of
Harry's not my face because if you did
get it from ariados for your money back
however the products are really really
well designed the gel feel so smooth on
the face the shave is nice and close but
it doesn't feel like you're nicking your
skin I would really really recommend you
to try it out it's done a great job on
my face imagine what you could do on
yours so Harry's were actually set up by
Jeff and Andy which sound like
completely made-up names but there we go
who would absolutely sick of being
ripped off with razors you know they did
they did what any normal person would do
they went and bought a factory
okay Paul that factory and they set up
Harry's and Harry's is almost half the
price of regular five blade races so
check them out you can get started to
date with your troll set for just three
pound 95 that's right three pound 95 and
you'll get a trial set delivered to you
from Harry's so guys if you want to
support the podcast and access this
offer go to harrys.com forward slash
trigger and you will get a razor handle
a fire blade cartridge shaving gel and
also a travel blade cover can't say
fairer than that there are children who
miss learning for all sorts of reasons
you know they end up at hospital for six
months because of something they move
away for six months they go to some
terrible school I mean what we will need
to realize is that there are lots of
children in the country in normal times
who don't really access the best
education there are lots of schools then
don't give them a good education so you
know I don't like the the juxtaposition
that we've got at the moment between as
it was before the perfect scenario with
brilliant schools that we're always
developing you know wonderful children
who always worked hard and the
disadvantaged came up and always able to
compete for the best jobs and now
because we've had a few weeks off school
everything is destroyed I mean yeah it
is more complex now of course it is but
Katherine how long do you think we
realistically we can continue with the
lockdown as it is now where you know
there is it's okay before we start to
get to a point where actually it starts
to have a very serious Dilla tereus long
term impact on on the kids and actually
on the teachers on the schools and on
society going forward as well as a
resolve this how long can we hire how
much more can we take yeah you say it's
okay at the moment I actually have no
idea I mean I'm not an economist I have
I have no idea what kind of effect this
is going to have on the economy and also
what kind of effect it's going to have
on people's songs you know I think about
our family
and families who lose jobs will be in
jeopardy um we have a lot of families
there'll be families who were single
moms who are cleaners well they'll have
just been fired by the various people
that they clean for how are they going
to support their families you know like
I really worry about our families from
that perspective um and I do think the
teachers don't do enough worrying for
those people what I mean is when the
teachers are saying we're not going back
until it's safe and that's that I think
that's unreasonable because that means
you're not giving enough thought to
those people whose salaries are not
secure whose and it's not just a salary
you know you might say oh but you're
getting some money it's you're running a
little business and you know you were in
the middle of growing it and now boom
it's just stop I don't know what kind of
effect that's gonna have on you and on
your family and I'm not an economist I'm
also not a virologist so I don't know
about the risks that we're taking when
we go back to school and I'm in from an
education point of view in terms of
actually the schools the education
system and also the learning of the kids
how much longer can we have a situation
where we are in a position that we're in
before it starts to actually cause
problems I mean it sounds like you you
feel like right now it's not the end of
the world it's not ideal but it's not
the end of the world but how long until
it starts to become actually a problem
well it is a problem I mean if they're
not in school they're not learning as
much um now I do think lower down you
know when it comes to children at four
and five and so on if they're not
learning how to read the impact is
greater I'm at secondary school um if
the children don't learn that chunk of
history or that chunk of science
well they don't learn that chunk of
history of that chunk of science I mean
I mean you could go on for a very long
time when people say you know I'm
considered myself to be a traditionalist
and then they're the people who I argue
it's who are considered to be the
progressives and when the progressives
say things like well
for life and you know you don't
necessarily need to read a Shakespeare
play well it's sort of true in the sense
that you know you're not gonna die if
you haven't read Shakespeare you're
gonna be okay I don't think your life is
gonna be as interesting I think it would
be a shame if you've never read
Shakespeare um and so they are missing
out on certain bits of learning but
they'll still learn when they come back
and what I would stress is that we
mustn't assume that those children were
all learning loads before the children
who come to school the children who are
not doing any work right now
they're their schools were always in a
bit of a fight with them to get them to
work right and depending on what kind of
school you went to if you went to a
really good school then they got you
working but if you went to a school that
wasn't so great because kids were never
doing any work anyway so yeah they can
read Shakespeare plays before they
didn't know much about history before
it's one of the things that I campaign
about all the time which is that we need
to make education better when people say
what are we going to do to fix this
situation the best thing I mean will
draw Michael Wilshaw came out yesterday
on Newsnight saying that what we need to
do is you have Saturday classes and
holiday classes and the kids can catch
up then and I genuinely thought have you
forgotten what it's like to be in school
mr. washer what are you talking about I
mean look let's just assume that all the
teachers are willing to do that in the
first place now that's gonna be
difficult anyway but let's assume that
they're all willing to come in on
Saturdays and the holidays and so on and
do that and I don't think it's
unreasonable for them not to be keen on
that because they've been working
through their Easter holidays they'll be
working through their may half term they
aren't working right now so I don't
think it would be unreasonable for them
to say wait a minute
I've got my own family how am I gonna
have my own children looked after on a
Saturday when I'm coming in and so on I
don't think it's reasonable but let's
say they're all in there and they're
willing to work the kids who didn't do
their work during lockdown are the same
kids who won't show up that Saturday
morning they're not suddenly going to
get inspired and saying I'm gonna give
up my Saturday and go in and work
because I didn't do enough work during
lockdown and their parents
is an absurd suggestion I don't
understand how it could ever be named
the fact is that all we can do when we
go back to school is present them with
excellent learning teaching excellent
behavior in the school that's what we
need excellent behavior will allow you
to social distance as much as you can
because what the kids aren't gonna do is
run around watching each other
deliberately you know in order to cause
chaos because they're used to behaving
themselves that's the behavior then
there's the idea well how do you teach
them obviously you want to teach them
the best way possible and I'm a real
traditionalist I believe the best way
possible is to be at the front of the
class leading the learning and imparting
knowledge that's what we should be doing
as teachers and more than ever I think
we're gonna have to do that when we get
back to school and I suspect lots of
teachers across the country will be
doing that but there's no outside fix
you know I know the government is under
a lot of pressure to look like they're
fixing so what we'll do is we'll buy
tablets
well baptize all the disadvantaged
children to give them tablets and then
everything will be all right
no it won't because they're gonna use
those taps though there's tablets to get
on snapchat so that is not a solution or
they say I know what we need to do let's
get them in on Sundays a little on the
holidays and then there's an argument
between those who think teachers are
lazy ah they just don't want to teach on
Saturdays and then there's the ones - no
no no got to get them in on Saturdays
well is anybody showing up is my point
you know if the kids aren't there then
there's not playing having this
conversation so it's it is complex it is
difficult there is no particular
solution apart from really good teaching
when we come back really good thinking
you know any of the leaders school
leaders who are listening to this need
to be thinking and I'm sure they are
already they need to be thinking how are
we going to manage this when we get back
to school to get the most that we can on
the kids and that is about giving them
excellent behavior systems and excellent
teaching and then the children will be
able to deliver I mean the the
perceptions they were coming out with
last night on news night was that a 50%
of children in the country are not doing
work at home you know and that's what
they know so they know that 50% aren't
doing it
that means far more than 50% are doing
it now I suspect
we find over 80% of our kids are doing
the work and we know it so and we know
it's a certain you know I I'm not we're
not being fooled and that's because
we've thought about how they're gonna
fool us oh we've got our spreadsheet
we've got our phone calls if we've got
everything happening so we know um but
it's true that those ones who are not
working I'm concerned about and it is a
genuine worry having said that your
seventh and eighth I do think that touch
up the ones the big ones to worry about
the attempts and the year 12s those are
the big ones and then the new ones down
on the other end I don't teach because
I'm at secondary but those four and five
year old six year olds who are learning
how to read learning how to write that
will have big a big impact on them but
you know ah sometimes a kid ends up in
hospital for six months me misses school
it that's what life is you just have to
pick up pick yourself up and keep on
going you know and Katherine what do you
think are going to be the long-term
implications of the fact that we're not
having a levels this year we're not
having GCSEs all these exams have been
scrapped these exams that kids have
worked really hard for do you think
that's going to have a long-term impact
on these children especially the
children who you know again come from
poorer backgrounds it's alright if you
go to an exclusive private school where
you know you've got somebody who's going
to be fight in your corner when it comes
to University yeah that's absolutely
true in fact you know it's really
interesting from my perspective the
thing that they've lost out on is that
build up in preparation towards a set of
exams it really it teaches you so much
about yourself about your working habits
about how to learn what you're good at
in terms of you know flashcards work for
me or reciting or you know that sort of
thing you learn how you things that you
like best when learning you learn how to
knock down and how to ignore all the
distractions and how how to make best
use of your time how to be efficient you
learn how to go to that revision session
that's going on even though it's not
mandatory you know how to the but you
learn how to buy into your life and how
to own your life you know it's it's
wonderful I mean people often in
teaching don't like exam
not all of those teachers are like that
but there aren't there there are some
teachers who are very critical exams
they feel it puts too much pressure on
children and so on I'm very I really
believe in exams for all of the skills
that they teach you in in the run-up to
those exams and so these children
haven't had that and I mean at least the
year Thirteen's had it at GCSE so there
is that I am particularly concerned
about year 11s who haven't had the GCSE
experience so when they then go on to do
other exams
whether that's BTech or a level and so
on later that will be the first time
that they're really coming across I mean
I know they had their SATs when they
were in year six but that's ages ago
they don't really remember that so
they've lost out on a whole load of
skills there which which is a shame and
actually I'm not sure it matters whether
you're poor or rich in that in that
situation I think everybody's an
innocent life situation and I'm you know
it's also interesting because I had a
friend she works at a private what are
the top private girls schools and you
know it's highly selective and she was
saying well you know they turn up to her
zoo lessons and so on but she she's
aware that they're on various apps when
she's talking to their kids you know the
keys take one thing away from this
interview so everyone to remember they
are kids I feel like it's forgotten what
kids alike you know think back to what
you were like as a child exemplary
Katherine they try and get away with
stuff the further the distance to a
school is from the child the less
opportunity we have to make sure that
they're on that right track I know I
said it at the beginning actually when
to Ormond teachers I said to them right
well we've got 98% of them you know
doing all the work that we want this is
going to it's going to go tell they're
gonna they're gonna start dropping off
as time goes on there's something gonna
start going yeah okay in this rhyme
again next week actually it doesn't
matter so much anymore what's happened
because they're children you know you
know the divide will it will exacerbate
that divide but that's just that's like
you know we just need to work hard when
we get back
hi guys and welcome to my bedroom or is
this otherwise called Palacio orgasmic
now this is a short video on behalf of
the angel comedy club now you may not be
aware but there is something on the
planet right now called the corona Horus
which is putting a little bit of a
spanner into the works of a lot of
people especially comedy clubs in
particular angel comedy club which is
where we film our show and angel have
been so supportive to us they've been
absolutely brilliant and when they now
need your help because they can't have
any shows they can't run a bar but the
problem is they still have to pay rent
so if you think a comedy club which puts
on acts like Stewart Lee Eddy is odd
Maria Bamford for a fiver and lets us
film for free is something that should
exist in the world I personally think it
should then all you have to do is give
it a little more bit of money to the
patron or maybe become a patron yourself
or putting a little bit of money to the
PayPal account I will have links
there'll be links at the bottom in order
for you to do that now if you can't do
that no worries at all we completely
understand but hopefully you'll be able
to maybe pop down to Angel one day to
see a live show from us or a whole host
of other fabulous comedians stay safe
and take care and do you think there are
any positives that come out of this for
for teachers for kids for their
education systems anything that we can
learn from this that otherwise might not
have happened any upsize at all did you
see to to what's happened it's lovely
people clapping and and it brings a
certain camaraderie and people pull
together and so on but I mean it's
devastating obviously what is happening
and
uh no I mean III don't see many
positives apart from the fact that the
country is trying to pull together and I
say the country is trying to pull
together I'm disappointed by the number
of people just saying crazy things if
accusations of the government yeah I'm
just saying the government has done
everything correctly obviously they're
making mistakes they're in a very
difficult situation um but I do think
it's I do worry about the press being so
vicious in the way that some sometimes
they can be just ordinary men and women
they get earned sixty seven thousand
pounds a year or whatever it is as a
politician you know they're just people
were trying to help their country oh you
might want to say Oh they've made
certain mistakes all the accusations of
Dominic Cummings I mean look he's just a
bit of a nerd can't dress properly I
mean I don't think he's this mastermind
you know rubbing his hands together
thinking how can i how can I get
everybody to do what I want and and I'll
say I just was in power these people are
just ordinary human beings trying to do
the best job that they can um in a very
very difficult situation I can just
imagine the stress that they got and
when you look at Tony Blair or Obama you
look at them pictures before they
started and they aged massively you know
I can only imagine you know Matt Hancock
must be aging 100 years everyday you
know there's one exception to that rule
and I actually tried to do a comedy
routine about it the Donald Trump is not
aged today the stresses of power
I have not affected him quite as much
well I actually it's a really important
thing that you bring up because I think
that you are someone who is in a
position of leadership you have a lot of
experience in that and I think one of
the things that I see from a lot of the
people who are you might be overly
critical and I agree with you of some of
the things that government I think they
just don't have any experience in being
a leader I mean the first thing you
learn when you lead anything whether
it's you know a school football team or
anything is the
you make mistakes all the time and there
is no getting away from it exactly that
that is exactly right and no friends of
mine
you are attacking the government and so
on or and I sort of think look you if
you're not a leader it's true they don't
have the experience
journalists obviously are not leaders
you know I mean obviously they are
journalists and they're great what they
do when I'm not being critical but they
also have never built something up from
the ground and let it and and when
you've done that you know one he'll
remember I spoke about trust at the
beginning how important it is to have
trust from your people because if you
don't have that then everything just
spins out of control the other thing
that you learn is just how hard it is to
be a leader and how hard it is to get it
right and that when you are hit by
things that you're not expecting you
have to make quick decisions and
sometimes you're going to get them wrong
and that's okay because you're human and
and you hope that you are surrounded by
people who are kind enough to forgive
you for those mistakes and I know that I
am with my staff I'm very lucky to have
my staff because when I make mistakes
they forgive me and they help me pick up
the pieces and we keep moving forward
and I feel that there aren't enough
people helping the government with that
now that doesn't mean that they
shouldn't put forward their alternative
views you know Peter Hitchens is always
gonna take an alternative view and it's
very an to the lockdown and that's fine
I just think that when were being
critical we need to do it in a
constructive way we need to we need to
make our arguments and we need to lay
out our evidence and reasons why as
opposed to just making these big
pronouncements we're not going back
until it's safe but what does that mean
so we're not going back for a year
example we're suggesting you know it's
um we have to be reasonable in what
we're saying and what we're accepting
and I feel that I'm trying to be
reasonable when I say look whatever the
government tells me to do I will do now
and people are surprised by that because
normally I get really annoyed about what
we're told to do in education and that's
because I'm an expert in education so I
know what works in the classroom and so
I'm very vocal about that I know for
instance the social distancing cannot
work in school
so I've been very vocal about that what
I don't know is how to get the country
moving again
and how to save all those small
businesses you know people assume that
it's just the the virus that's killing
people but you know there's all sorts of
stops to show that they're more for
instance battered women at home who have
been killed in the last few weeks there
all sorts of people people will become
anything suicide because of their
situation financial situations you know
we mustn't just assume but the only
thing that kills is the virus there are
other things that kill too and I'm no
expert so that's why I can't make a
decision
I'm simply bringing alarm bells and
saying hey look everybody we need to
think about this and is it very very
difficult now to sort of plan a coherent
strategy where you were talking about
the culture war in education where you
were on one side and you've got
progressives on the other side can you
actually formulate a coherent strategy
when you've got those two sides bumping
heads essentially and that's the point
that's exactly the point which is that
all the ends up happening is each side
is shouting nobody's actually listening
to each other and it's it's really sad I
just remembered that I didn't mention
actually about PPE because I that's one
thing that teachers say you know they
need to have PPE and and I don't think
it's an unreasonable thing for teachers
to be provided with PPE
while teaching uh that would certainly
go a long way to gaining the trust of
teachers so if government wanted to do
something to make teachers feel at ease
that would be something
having said that PPE is difficult to get
into the hospital obviously they need to
be there first so um maybe that's not
possible but not PPE for children that's
silly and the reason why it's silly is
because if you know kids don't worry kid
in two minutes
exactly they'll lose it it'll be
finished there's no point so the only
people who should PPE tools would be the
teachers I thought it was really clever
than way in which supermarkets almost
immediately enacted you know they got a
screen up he was within days that they
screams up and they have their stickers
on the floor for two meters apart and
they have no system they just changed
everything instantly that sort of thing
might be you know what I'm saying is
that systems and schools and leaders and
schools needs to be thinking well how
can we make it so that we can protect
our staff the best as possible the other
thing I didn't mention actually in terms
of running a school and how difficult it
is the idea of going back is that we
mustn't forget if they're telling you to
send home everybody who has a call and
if they're telling you to send home
everyone who has an underlying issue and
that that includes everyone everybody
but you got all the kids that's a
disaster okay so we've got we do have to
think really carefully about how it's
done now you may just want to send on
the staff who have underlying issues
what I understand 50% of people carrying
it wouldn't show symptoms anyway so you
know what do you do you've got five
people the symptoms five people without
symptoms who do you say you know people
like me had teachers who are having to
make difficult decisions in difficult
circumstances and that's not me
complaining if they are also in a
difficult situation but I suppose my
plea is to aim on listening to this to
just be kind to those of us who are
having to make difficult decisions in
difficult circumstances
nobody wants anyone to die nobody wants
to put anyone's life in danger
everyone's trying to do their best now
we might disagree about how that best
needs to be achieved even the scientists
disagree with each other about the right
way forward so if even the scientists
are disagree then we need to recognize
that there isn't obviously one clear
route about what to do now we do need to
speak you know carefully so you
mentioned Donald Trump earlier and I
think that Donald Trump has been rather
you know loose with his language poor
leadership leaders need to be very
careful about what they say and how they
say it
especially when others
listening to you and then we'll go off
and copy what you said and we'll have
misunderstood what you said and it's
easy to say well they're just stupid
well you know the fact is people don't
know and they're listening to you so you
do have to be careful as a leader um
there is a response we have a
responsibility and I say we because I'm
a leader we have a responsibility to
think very carefully about the things
that we're saying and what we're doing
in our actions and people have a
responsibility I think to be kind in
their judgment of us and there's a
question I wanted to ask you actually
lost episode Katherine and we touched on
this earlier in the interview which is
teacher bashing teachers are one of the
most important roles this country any
society can have we all remember a great
teacher we all remember a teacher that
changed our lives that inspired our love
of learning from for a particular
subject why is it in this country we do
not have respect for teachers because I
was a teacher for 12 years and I saw it
day in day out that's what I make is
probably part of it why do you think
because I've been able to have those
conversations and hear what people say
in a way that I've in my own circle of
friends and so on I wouldn't I wouldn't
have heard these opinions because the
people I know tend to like teachers I
not what I hear is often I hear I had a
teacher when I was in year 7 it was mean
to me and I hate him and they kept that
anger because there was a teacher who
once did X and they hold that against
everyone
I remember Diane Abbott once talking
about a teacher of her so this had been
in the 1980s and she'd written an
excellent essay and it was brilliant but
she was told that it was bad and she was
stupid and so on and no doubt the
teacher was racist and that was what was
going on this was in the 1980s now she's
taking that so to heart I feel that it
informs her judgment of teach it is
informed her judgment of teachers since
she's been well known to be accusing
schools of being all sorts of things you
know in in the past and and I think that
that's because she can't let go of that
particular experience I think I find
that with lots of my followers on
Twitter and so on that they are very
angry about a particular teacher um they
also have a certain way of they believe
that the school ought to teach in a
particular way and if the teacher if the
teachers not doing that they get very
angry about it and my my position on
that is that look you're gonna get a
variety different schools if you can
have choice if you live in a big city
great you've got choice try and choose a
school that best matches your values um
if you don't well sadly that's just the
way that it is and you need to recognize
that there is going to be a particular
way in which that school leader that
head teacher is going to leave that
school and you know they might have a
way of having the teachers all pull
together and deliver a teaching in a
particular kind of way or they might be
a lot more free about it they might let
teachers just get up to whatever they
want there are different styles of
schools and it's just it's just the way
that it is and you're not gonna get a
school any school you will never find a
school which delivers exactly what you
want you as a parent and this is key and
this is something that this pandemic is
really demonstrating for me which is
that parents have forgotten that part of
their role is to teach their children
okay it isn't just the role of teachers
you as a parent before your child goes
to school she'll be trying to teach them
how to read you as a parent should be
meeting with them regularly every single
day all of the time I would say right up
to the age of 15 you know you as a
parent should be encouraging them if you
are able to afford it try and get them
playing a musical instrument and if you
can't afford it get them on get them
doing chess online for instance right
now you can go on to chess kid calm and
you can get free subscription in fact
all the time you could have played chess
kid you don't get a subscription but you
could have done it for free online where
all the families sat round teaching the
children how to play chess
or stop round playing Monopoly you know
the fact
the parents have just found out that
responsibility to schools and I do think
that this happens because the state has
become all-powerful in in our society
and we are just used to looking to the
state we are dependent on the state for
everything tell me one thing tell me
what to do tell me you know so when it
comes to our own children we do not
recognize that our responsibility as
parents is we are the first black hole
in teaching them they send to school so
yes they're gonna be taught physics GCSE
you might not know much physics they're
gonna be taught history GCSE maybe
you're not an expert at that
but you there's loads it's certainly a
primary level you should be there every
step along the way and I think too many
parents are not fulfilling their
responsibilities on that and then they
like to just blame so they'll just blame
the teacher it's because the teacher
hasn't told him well what have you
taught him as a parent um so there is
also I mean look I'm blaming parents but
there is also the unions the unions are
one of the big reasons why teachers are
hated because they give us all of that
name I'm constantly embarrassed
constantly humiliated but things the
unions are saying I mean I just they
make us look like we're lazy that's what
they make us look like and what I could
ask anybody any non education is
listening to this to listen to believe
me when I say the vast majority of
teachers are not like them okay the
unions speak supposedly for us but there
are many teachers who they are not
speaking for it's just that those
teachers don't have a voice there are
all sorts of teachers right now who and
I don't mean me because I do have a
voice I mean giving a voice to the
voiceless here in trigonometry is out
there right now who are working like
mine who are delivering wonderful
lessons and videos and they're doing
everything they're marking their work as
it's coming back to them on photos on
Google classroom and so on they're doing
everything they can for the kids and
then the union's say we don't want this
we don't want that and then the parents
think oh you're just a bunch of lazy
teachers but they're not it's just that
they don't have a voice and they're not
able to tell you everything they're
doing
for your children teachers every teacher
I've ever known all of them they all go
into teaching because they love kids
they go into teaching because they want
to change the world that's what they
want to do they want to have impact on
the world and they think that my
teaching little children but you know
when I say little they can be 15 but you
know by teaching children you're able to
have impact on the world that's what you
can do as a teacher and that's why it's
the most wonderful job and every teacher
goes into it for that reason now it's
true that not every teacher comes out of
it on the other side still thinking that
and that is because the system can grind
them down and grind them down through a
variety of reasons my other trigonometry
interview that I've done with you
explaining some of the reasons why
teachers get drowned down because I
believe the system is but it's it's
better than it was I was gonna say it's
broken but it's better than it was ten
years ago I think we're on a trajectory
moving upwards in this country and
things are getting better all of the
time so I'm really positive about
education at the moment where we're
going but there's no question that
teachers are under a lot of stress it's
really hard being a teacher and they
give a lot to the system and sometimes
it can break them and so again I would
ask families who are perhaps a bit too
judgmental of teachers give him a break
you know it's hard that doesn't mean
every teacher is good you know and I do
think the unions again the unions can
often come in and defend teachers who
are bad and you know insist on keeping
them in the classroom
I do think the unions do us far fewer
favors then you know I mean look they
have a role to play I'm not saying they
shouldn't exist but I do wish that they
weren't as rabid as they are that makes
a lot of sense we've come to the end of
our hour with you it's always a pleasure
speaking with you such a passionate
advocate for the things that you believe
and you believe them based on your
experience and speaking of your
experience what is the one thing that
you see right now that is not being
talked about that you think we really
should be talking about as a society
yeah well you know what I just said
actually about the state I mean you know
I've said this before I think in your
last interview you know we have got so
used to depend
on the state and I don't just mean
people were on welfare okay is an
example we just expect the schools to
teach your children and we've forgotten
about the responsibilities that we have
to our own children um we we expect the
government to sort out this pandemic and
you know they haven't sorted it and
people are dying well you haven't done
your job we think psychologically what
does that do to a country what does that
do to us when we have abandoned personal
responsibility when we have abandoned a
sense of duty
you know once upon a time we all talked
about duty and how we have a duty to
better the community to better the world
to go out there and do something so that
you can sit on your death bed at the end
of your life and look back and say look
actually III lived III had impact on the
world you know that combination of duty
and responsibility I think has been
eroded over the last you know several
decades and and I think sadly that has
to do with the influence of the state
when you take away too much from an
individual in terms of what they need
what they are responsible for they they
forget how to be how to be human how how
to live you know and I say you wanna
live you don't to just exist and that
requires buying into those concepts of
personal responsibility Duty obligation
behaving in a decent manner kindness
gratitude all of those which are all you
know sentiments and ideas that we try
and instill in our children at Michaela
that sounds like a party political
broadcast for the Labor Party for any
party these days nobody talks you ever
hear a politician talking about personal
responsibility about duty about
obligations never come out of the mouth
it doesn't exist they don't we don't
talk in that fashion anymore
and um that is sad I think that in 2020
we just lost something and I think we
need to get it back I think you're right
Katherine it's so interesting the point
that you make about people expecting the
government to be able to just solve any
problem I see so many people now going
oh look look how many people have died
and you're going yet it's a pandemic
people die in the pendant that's what
happens you know like your government
can't just fix everything completely
without any concept extremely sad it's
and people sadly always look to blame
somebody same teachers point you know
why do they hate teachers because they
want an explanation for why their child
can't do maths you know you have to get
out of that mentality what is my
responsibility what can I do to change
this that's what we should always be
thinking and Catherine you mentioned
there's a book that you're working on at
the moment as well tell us about that
before we let go yeah we have got a book
called the power of culture it talks
about all the ideas actually that I was
just mentioning about duty and personal
responsibility and so on and how we try
and instill these values in the children
at school and how important I think
these values are to to a school and to
education and I'd say this book the
power of culture it's written by all of
our teachers well not all of them but
most of them and we do say some very
controversial things I am a bit nervous
about it because what we're saying
you're not really meant to think let
alone say as a teacher but I think it's
important for us to to move to move the
to move the conversation on from where
it's at in education at the moment so
we're where to having a book launch
online book launch on zoom' at 6:00 p.m.
on Wednesday next week on the 6th so and
everyone's invited I've been tweeting
out anyone can come they just need to
sign up and there's an interview with
many and I'll be talking more about the
book so you know your your viewers are
very welcome to come along fantastic
thanks so much it sounds like you're
gonna trigger some people which is what
we always approve of here trigonometry
so thanks so much Katherine and
everybody for watching we'll see you in
a week's time thanks for watching guys
as always subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the Bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out and follow us on
all the social media at trigger Potter
and also leave us a nice review on
iTunes and spread the word